♪ ♪
>> Jeanine: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY."
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION TO
THE LATEST CONTROVERSY SWIRLING
AROUND ROBERT MUELLER'S TEAM IS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "TRUMPED
DANGEROUS DEMOCRACY," ALAN
DERSHOWITZ.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE
TONIGHT.
YOU WROTE A FASCINATING ARTICLE
SAYING THAT TRUMP DOESN'T NEED
TO FIRE MUELLER AND YOU SAY THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN TACTICS THAT
TALK TO US.
>> I LEARNED ABOUT THIS FROM THE
GREAT COACH OF THE
BOSTON CELTICS WHO TOLD ME ONE
DAY WHEN WE WERE SITTING AT A
CELTICS GAME THAT WHENEVER HE
USED TO SCREAM AT AN OFFICIAL IN
YELLOW THE OFFICIAL HE WOULD
ALWAYS GET THE NEXT CALL IN HIS
FAVOR.
THEN I HEARD THE SAME THING FROM
BASEBALL PLAYER WHO SAID WHEN HE
PROTESTED A BALL OR A STRIKE HE
WOULD GET THE NEXT CALL.
I THINK THAT'S THE TACTIC THAT
IS BEING USED HERE.
YOU CONTINUOUSLY ATTACK MUELLER.
YOU BRING UP EVERY POSSIBLE
ISSUE WHETHER IT BE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, HIRING THE WRONG
PEOPLE, FAILING TO GET A WARRANT
FOR THE EMAILS, USING THE
WHO IS SO CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
INTEGRITY AND HIS REPUTATION MAY
VERY WELL BE INCLINED TO LEAN
OVER BACKWARDS TO SHOW HIS
FAIRNESS AND TO MAKE A CLOSE
CALL IN FAVOR OF TRUMP RATHER
THAN AGAINST TRUMP.
I SUSPECT THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THEY ARE PLAYING THE REFS AS
IT'S CALLED IN SPORTS.
>> Jeanine: ASIDE FROM THE
BASEBALL ANALOGIES, YOU ARE AN
ATTORNEY.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
RULES, THERE ARE GUIDELINES.
WE WERE TALKING WITH US AND THE
OTHER BLOCK.
IF YOU HAVE POSSESSION OF
DOCUMENTS AS A LAWYER THAT IS
PRIVILEGED AND CONTAINS
PRIVILEGED INFORMATION, THEN YOU
ARE ETHICALLY OBLIGATED TO AT
LEAST NOTIFY THE PERSON WHO'S
INFORMATION YOU HAVE AND YET --
MUELLER'S TEAM KNOWS ALL OF US.
ARE THEY PLAYING BY THE RULES OR
ARE THEY JUST HURTING THEMSELVES
HERE?
>> THEY ARE PLAYING THAT THEY
HAVE THESE THOUSANDS OF EMAILS
AND THEY HAVEN'T EVEN GONE
THROUGH THEM YOU HAVE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER ANY OF THEM
ARE PRIVILEGED.
THEY ARE ALSO TAKING THE
POSITION THAT NOTHING IS
PRIVILEGED BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS
ON NOTICE THAT THIS WAS THE
POSSESSION OF THE GOVERNMENT,
THE PROPERTY OF THE GOVERNMENT,
NOT THE PROPERTY OF INDIVIDUALS.
BUT THAT VIOLATES CORE NOTIONS
OF CIVIL LIBERTIES.
PEOPLE HAVE REASONABLE
EXPECTATIONS OF PRIVACY.
I DON'T EXPECT THAT THEIR EMAILS
TO THEIR LAWYER FOR THE EMAILS
TO THE FUTURE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT WOULD BE LOOKED
INTO WITHOUT A SUBPOENA OR A
SEARCH WARRANT.
YOU USED TO BE A JUDGE, YOU KNOW
YOU JUST GO TO A JUDGE AND MAKE
ANY KIND OF PLAUSIBLE
WHY NOT DO IT?
WHEN YOU'RE GOING AFTER THE
PRESIDENT WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO BE
SLOPPY BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PEOPLE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EVERY
MISTAKE YOU MAKE AND HE HAS MADE
TOO MANY.
>> Jeanine: WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT A.GOV AND NO EXPECTATION
OF PRIVACY, THIS PRESIDENTIAL
TRANSITION TEAM, THERE ARE
STATUTES THAT APPLY TO THEM IN
PARTICULAR, REGULATIONS, MEMOS
OF UNDERSTANDING.
I CAN GET THE YOU HAVE NO
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY ON
CERTAIN SERVERS, BUT THIS IS
SURROUNDED BY PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION AND REGULATIONS AND
MEMOS OF UNDERSTANDING.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
I THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> OF COURSE.
LET ME TELL YOU THE HYPOCRISY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE MAKING THE FOLLOWING TWO
ARGUMENTS.
NUMBER ONE THEY SAY THAT OF
WASN'T A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
HE WASN'T THE PRESIDENT YET SO
THEY CAN'T BE EXACTING PRIVILEGE
THEY CAN'T BE EXACTING PRIVILEG
PRIVILEGE.
ON THE OTHER HAND THEY SAY THEY
WERE PUBLIC OFFICIALS FOR
PURPOSES OF GETTING THE EMAILS.
YOU CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
YOU HAVE TO PICK A THEORY AND
THEY ARE INCONSISTENT.
>> Jeanine: YOU HAVE TO PICK A
THEORY BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
MUELLER IS THIS WHOLE THING WITH
PETER STRZOK AND THE WOMAN WITH
WHOM HE WAS HAVING THE AFFAIR,
LISA PAGE WORKED FOR THE FBI.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THEY WILL
HAVE TO GET AN INSURANCE POLICY
AND THEY HAVE THIS MEETING AND
AROUND THE SAME TIME, STRZOK IN
CHARGE OF COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
THAT WE START THIS RUSSIA PROBE
ON THE ELECTRIC TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
MUELLER DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT STRZOK AND THE REALIZATION
THAT HE FOUND OUT THAT THERE
WERE ALL OF THIS ANTI-TRUMP
SENTIMENT.
VENOMOUS, IT'S HORRIBLE.
>> DID GET RID OF HIM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, HE KEPT THAT
SECRET.
HE DID IT AS SOON AS HE FOUND
OUT ABOUT IT, BUT HE DIDN'T TELL
THE PUBLIC UNTIL MUCH LATER AS A
LOOK, I THINK MUELLER IS A
DECENT AND HONORABLE MAN WHO
CARES DEEPLY ABOUT HIS
REPUTATION, IS TRYING TO DO THE
>> Jeanine: HE'S MADE A FEW.
>> WHEN YOU ARE GOING AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT WAS A REPUBLICAN
YOU TAKE MUCH MORE CARE AND WHO
YOU PUT ON THE INVESTIGATIVE
TEAM.
IF YOU MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
CAESAR'S WIFE.
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE ABOVE
REPROACH.
HE DIDN'T PASS THAT TEST.
NOW HE'S BEING CARELESS IN
OBTAINING EVIDENCE WITHOUT
WARRANTS OR SUBPOENAS.
THOSE PLAY RIGHT INTO THE HANDS
OF THE TRUMP TEAM AND THERE'S
JUST NO GOOD REASON WHY A GOOD
LAWYER SHOULD DO THAT.
I WOULD NEVER ALLOW SOMEBODY
WORKING FOR ME TO DO ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S INTERESTING
HOW THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM IS
BORE ON THIS ONE.
I THINK THE FACTS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
BY THE WAY, YOU SAY THAT HE'S
MADE ONE OR TWO ERRORS.
I THINK YOU MADE AN ERROR RATE
FROM THE GET-GO.
THE FACT THAT HE APPLIED FOR THE
JOB TO BE THE HEAD OF THE FBI
AND DIDN'T GET IT, THE FACT THAT
HE IS SO TIGHT WITH JAMES COMEY
AND THE TWO OF THEM THINK THEY
HAVE MADE HISTORY TOGETHER WHEN
THAT IS CLASSIC CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
YOU KNOW IT, ADMIT IT!
>> I THINK THAT THE VERY IDEA OF
APPOINTING A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
DEFEATED THE PURPOSE OF ANY
INQUIRY.
WE WANT AN OPEN, PUBLIC INQUIRY,
ABIDE PARTISAN INQUIRY TO MAKE T
ABIDE PARTISAN INQUIRY TO MAKE E
ABIDE PARTISAN INQUIRY TO MAKE Y
CLOSED DOORS, GRAND JURY, WE
WILL NEVER LEARN ANYTHING.
EVERYONE IS YELLING LOCK HIM UP,
LOCK HER UP.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY TO PROCEED.
WE SHOULDN'T BE CRIMINALIZING
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES.
WE SHOULD BE GATHERING
INFORMATION FROM EVERY SIDE.
THIS WAS A TERRIBLE ELECTION.
IT WAS AN ELECTION FILLED WITH
PROBLEMS AND WE OUGHT TO USE IT
AS A LESSON TO AVOID PROBLEMS
LIKE THIS IN THE FUTURE AND A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS THE WORST WAY
TO DO IT.
>> Jeanine: AM I HEARING YOU
SAY THAT EVEN IF THESE OPEN
PROCESSES, WE FIND THE LAW WAS
VIOLATED WE DON'T PROSECUTE
PEOPLE?
>> NO.
USE THE CRIMINAL LAW AT LAST,
NOT FIRST.
WHEN YOU APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS
WE KNOW THERE WERE CRIMES
COMMITTED, NOW LET'S FIND OUT
WHAT CRIMES THEY WERE.
SHOULD WORK.
WE SHOULD FIRST DO AN
INVESTIGATION, OPEN-ENDED,
NONPARTISAN 9/11 TYPE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jeanine: WHY WAS HE ALLOWED
TO GO TO THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE?
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
HE'S THE GUY WHOSE WIFE WORKS
FOR FUSION GPS ON THE ANTI-TRUMP
DOSSIER AND THAT HE HAS A
CONCLUDE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
TRY AND GET THEIR STORY
STRAIGHT.
THAT DOESN'T HELP EITHER.
>> EVERYBODY SHOULD -- WE SHOULD
LOOK INTO ALL OF THESE ISSUES TO
AVOID RECURRENCE IN THE FUTURE.
WE HAVE TO CLEAN UP OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM AND WE SHOULDN'T DO IT
THROUGH A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SOMEBODY BEFORE MENTIONED THAT
MUELLER SHOULD APPOINT AN ETHICS
CONSULTANT.
I HAD PROPOSED THAT IN MY
ARTICLE THIS MORNING.
PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE.
THE TRUMP PEOPLE WOULD RATHER
SEE HIM HAVE ETHICAL PROBLEMS
BECAUSE IT GIVES THEM AMMUNITION
BECAUSE IT GIVES THEM AMMUNITIO
AMMUNITION.
IT'S IN MUELLER'S INTEREST TO
CLEAN UP HIS ACT AND GO FORWARD